Хтось має бути лідером, маяком. Вона каже: "Я буду лідером!" Як її батько!
Молодець! За неньку-Україну! Ну от в неї очі горять!
"Я буду так, як батько, я буду військовою, буду вчитися".
Помста буде потім, це підготовка до помсти!
Усі ці слова - про мотивацію Ярослави Журавель. Їй 15.
Змалку вона мріяла стати професійною спортсменкою.
Втім війна Росії проти України змінила її життя у дитячому віці
і змусила шукати шляхи помсти за смерть рідного батька на фронті - у військовій справі.
Зброя поклалася!
Магазин поклався і ось в такому положенні чекаєте.
До мішеней! Підняли і побігли до мішеней!
Під час вогневої підготовки Ярослава Журавель хвалиться відмінними результатами: 9 влучань у мішень з 10.
Це її улюблена частина тренувань на полігоні зі взводом.
Разом з іншими вихованцями Київського військового ліцею імені Богуна
вона навчається задля мети - одного дня стати до лав ЗСУ.
Спочатку переживала, адреналін!
А потім, як стріляла, сподобалося!
Хочу бути, як тато. Піти його слідами.
Тато був розвідником в морській піхоті.
Спершу в 20 ОМПБ, потім в 93-й.
З 2014 року батько дівчини - Ярослав Журавель - служив у зоні
поблизу окупованих Луганщини та Донеччини.
Про свою службу він не міг розповідати багато, втім донька захоплювалася місією батька.
Я пам’ятаю його веселим, добрим, сильним і сміливим.
Ми або грали в якісь ігри по типу футболу, або ще я тоді ходила на кікбоксінг,
приходив до мене в зал, дивився, як я займалася.
Він завжди мене підтримував на змаганнях.
Липень 2020 року. Ярослава очікувала тата з фронту.
За день до свого дня народження, 13-річчя, вона дізналася про його смерть.
Від поранення під час завдання під Зайцевим на Донеччині він стік кров’ю,
не діставшись з "сірої зони" до позицій побратимів. Про ті події Ярослава не може говорити і донині.
Коли були зроблені ці Світлини з дня поховання, Ярослава вже знала - вона хоче продовжити справу батька.
Того ж року вона, чемпіонка України з кікбоксингу,
залишила професійний спорт і вступила до військового ліцею - у свої 13.
Руш!
У нас в кожному взводі по три дівчинки. Вони молодці - пробігли найкраще!
Ярослава одна з перших прибігає під час випробувань.
Керівник ліцею, генерал-майор Ігор Гордійчук, запевняє:
дівчина прийшла до закладу відмінно підготовленою на свій вік,
тож зараз належить до спортивної спецгрупи.
Вона в першому взводі, спортивний взвод. Вони будуть показувати приклад.
Хтось має бути лідером, маяком. Вона каже: "Я буду лідером!" Як її батько! Молодець!
Саме жага до боротьби, до цих ідеалів Євромайдану,
ми в НАТО, в Європі, і в тому числі і помста!
За неньку-Україну! Ну от в неї очі горять!
Перше і основне, що ми бачимо в аптечці - це турнікет.
Накладаю максимально високо, фіксуємо, затягуємо.
Практичні заняття в ліцеї Ярослава дуже цінує.
Під час перших місяців повномасштабної війни дівчині довелося евакуюватися з Києва,
тож навчання було дистанційним. В той час Ярослава та її дідусь
постійно були на зв’язку з побратимами батька.
Так вони вирішили разом бути корисними для ЗСУ як волонтери.
Слава Україні!
У перерві між тренуваннями Ярослави дідусь приїхав навідати онуку
й обговорити чергову допомогу для української армії - благодійний аукціон.
Ну, я буду навчатися, одночасно допомагати там якось,
не знаю, дистанційно, а ми хочемо відкрити цей аукціон, виставити білети Кличків,
бо в нас тато дуже хотів побачитися з ними і побути в них на боях.
Щоб приїхав Кличко, розписався на білеті і виставити, і допомога буде на ЗСУ.
То це в неї такі плани, мрії, плани, цілі, вона до цього йде.
Це нація, це гени, в неї вже закладена ця оборона, ця країна,
воно вже в серці, в мізках, кругом, що за життя цієї країни,
за цвіт оцього дерева, за цвіт отієї троянди,
віддані життя, життя батьків, братів, дідів!
Дідусь та онука регулярно збирають кошти на одяг, їжу та спорядження для ЗСУ,
а цього літа дівчина з дідусем здійснила два заповітних бажання -
відремонтувати старе батькове авто та передати його воїнам особисто - на Донеччині.
Усе це - в пам'ять про батька та інших полеглих героїв.
Ми маємо їх пам'ятати, бо вони за нашу свободу поклали своє життя.
І це все, що ми можемо робити, щоб пам'ятати про них.
Мрія служити в ЗСУ і волонтерство врятували Ярославу від прірви горя,
в якій вона опинилася у перші роки після втрати тата, каже дідусь дівчинки.
Почалися процеси дуже погані. На базі цієї психіки, все.
На обличчі… В неї стало повертати обличчя.
Ярослава з мамою поїхала на реабілітацію в Болгарію.
На цей час вже було заборонено займатися спортом.
Після реабілітації вона повернулася і вона чітко сказала,
що все, робіть що хочете, дід, робіть що хочете, я буду так, як батько,
я буду військовою, буду вчитися.
Помста буде потім, це підготовка до помсти, це просто підготовка.
Так страшно казати, все-таки 15 років, дитина, ну…
Жертовно служити Україні, самовіддано захищати її від будь-яких нападників!
Клянемося, ми майбутні захисники української держави!
Читаючи ці рядки військової присяги, Ярослава дуже хвилюється.
У жовтні вона повторить її на урочистому зборі ліцеїстів до Дня захисників та захисниць.
А нині багато днів вона проводитиме на тренувальному полігоні,
бо попереду - нові навчання на шляху до мети.
Я хочу піти в розвідку, в Одесі поступити, і там бути розвідницею.
Головне, щоб була мотивація і осмислити,
чи ти реально цього хочеш, піти в таку справу.